aux etats unis une étude commandée par
l'organisme eco watch a détecté des
traces de glyphosate dans des produits à
base d'avoine comme des céréales à
déjeuner des barres tendres et du gruau
le glyphosate c'est l'ingrédient actif
du pesticide round up 2 months and
aubert dans l'analyse six produits
contenaient du glyphosate dans des
concentrations supérieures à la limite
permise
entre autres dans du cru au miel et noix
de la marque quaker dont des serial à la
cannelle de marques cheerios à
surveiller parce que certains de ces
produits sont disponibles au canada
trouver des pesticides dans des aliments
prêts à consommer à base d'avoine
c'est une première